hi I'm Charlize Theron hi I'm Nick Kroll
and we are gonna take which Addams
Family character are you BuzzFeed
BuzzFeed quiz quiz the quiz thank you
all right we're gonna do it all right
what word would your friends use to
describe you
moody unpredictable eccentric bizarre
opinionated confident cynical loner
persuasive I would say most of these
yeah can you do a mixture yes click on
all of them or do you have to only click
on one only only click on that it's not
how the world works I know
sure release is a multi-faceted person
with so many different dimensions I
however am a loner
I have no friends vigor that's what I
need what did you click on confident as
one of your closest friends I would say
I think of you as confident I feel like
after you spend a weekend in South by
Southwest that's where that's an
automatic yes we're in our industry like
I was texting him we texted alphas make
sure we weren't wearing the same thing
which image brings you the most pleasure
there's a man with a mouth fur and I I
do have like one of those in my house
this feels like a Marie
what's her name Marie Kondo this is like
a Tori condo question that sparks joy
what sparks joy the hand coming out of
the grave yes the scary none the woman
eating spaghetti brains is it just a
bunch of skeletons is it uh though
someone caught inside of a television
what's the last one
like a monster coming in through a
doorway I'm gonna go with the first one
I'm gonna go teeth eyes I'm going with
the TV what's your favorite color black
midnight onyx charcoal Raven sable Jade
oil M&E
black is this for my porn searches or is
this you know I find this question is
just be so raven I'm gonna pick a fun
way to torture your family members oh
here we go give them a spin on the wheel
of pain play Russian roulette with the
family guillotine dump hundreds of frogs
into a bathtub while they're taking a
shower replace a lot of work that's a
lot of that is a lot of work well cuz
it's like you got to go to the store you
gotta buy the Froyo oh you catch frogs
from Africa that's how we get our frogs
I'm from the suburbs we go to a store
and we buy the Frog then we put them on
leashes and walk around the mall replace
their morning alarm with ASMR sounds of
someone eating pickles replace their
eyedrops with lemon juice that's a good
trick I did that too we prank each other
all the time on set when we were doing
the Addams family on set call for
eyedrops and I'd give her lemon juice
drop mini tranches in their bed while
they're sleeping put laxatives in their
spaghetti she did that to me I like that
I wish you did that to me this is the
stand regular BuzzFeed quiz we swap the
filling in their favorite Oreos with
toothpaste that's sort of the mint Oreo
that's an easy one because I have both
of those ingredients yeah shrink all
their clothes in the wash and hang them
back up in their closet that's what
happens to my clothes I'm doing the
laxatives okay nothing funnier than poop
there is honestly in my opinion I'm
gonna do dump hundreds of frogs in the
bathtub oh they're taking a shower frogs
is the word I use for taking a dump
though pick a late night snack a heart
fingers that's like an octopus baby
octopus yeah it's worms eysan eysan ass
dude look second of all right it's a
punch and i sangria maggots are those
maggots like maggots wormy things and
those are um those are crickets you can
eat crickets anywhere an hour I know
it's the only protein I get
I'm actually gonna go with crickets I
hear they're delicious I've heard
they're delicious to go with crickets
I'm gonna go with the I sangria I want
to see the inside of my belly I don't
actually think you would eat that snack
though so I think that's unfair okay
they're gonna bring everything out you
know that right this is all gonna come
out the end then we're gonna have to
actually eat it all yeah I just someone
put a bunch of laxatives in my spaghetti
sauce what I'm cleared out I'm ready to
eat again which code speaks to your dark
soul I wish I had more time to seek out
the dark forces and join their hellish
crusade I hope that someday you'll know
that and describable joy of having
children and playing someone else to
raise them paying someone else paying
someone else to this is a little bit too
real okay yeah the first one I wish I
had more time to seek out the dark force
entering their house and this is that's
an Eleanor Roosevelt look so sweet just
like a little entree this is my costume
I'm a homicidal maniac they they look
just like everyone else okay and that's
JFK I'll clean my room in exchange for
your immortal soul that's what my kids
Oh
so much you don't understand the human
spirit it is a hard thing to kill
Malcolm X that was nothing special I
think that was my it was either Malcolm
X for Vin Diesel you'll meet someone
very special someone who won't press
charges
that is my tinder profile it looks
familiar of course the gates of hell
that's my address
that's eat me that's that's online it's
risky that's on my grandmother's
tombstone
I'm gonna go I wish I had more time to
see kill the dark voices and join their
hellish crusade cuz I'm look and I'm an
Eleanor Roosevelt fan I went with your
grandmother's tombstone eat me yeah
totally
she's a pet Oh kitty cat cute bunny
little black pig
what is that a Panther Panther a pitbull
there's a baby pea yeah there's a paper
business Thanks that's next there's an
owl and there's a monkey eating
spaghetti with chopsticks not true not
true
what does I hope you do us he's using a
tool mm-hmm to get the the ant we
studied is that the part of Africa that
you're the Jane Goodall part yeah yeah
I'm from the jingled oh yeah there's
also a beautiful black stallion yes so
gone with the pit you're going with the
sweet pit you got pissed no problem I
masturbated to black stallion growing up
so could you get Uncle Fester I'm Uncle
Fester you got me and I got the thing
which is the hand it's not the thing
it's just thing thank you you are the
out of town the expert I got Thing Thing
yeah which is how I masturbated to Fox
tell you that's thank you thank you yes
exactly correct so this has been the
BuzzFeed which Adams family character
are you x-rated version goes to the
movie The Addams Family to see The
Addams Family with Charlize Theron his
Uncle Fester
with Charlize Theron his Uncle Fester
we'll see you guys on the Internet
[Music]